I have fought
[Music]
and Fallen
times Beyond Counting
only to be reforged and you
I feel my Humanity dulled
my memories eroded
my burden way is heavily
in sigma's name
we shall bring order to the Savage Realm
for I am stormcast and my War wages
eternal
[Music]
Realms of Ruin is a real-time strategy
game that brings to life age of Sigma
and all of its savagery you'll get to
see games workshops amazing Miniatures
authentically realized in stunning
detail thanks to our wonderful Dev team
and you'll command them on the field of
battle it will be available on
PlayStation 5 Xbox series X and S and PC
today we're revealing our first two
factions for Realms of ruin the Oreck
cruel boys and the stormcast eternals
the storm
race of Warriors of Sigmar reforged from
Human souls to fight the forces of chaos
another of our factions is the Sinister
cruel boys foul oryx Twisted by the
masmal swamp which they come from they
Revel in cunning tricks and traps but
being aurix they also live to destroy
everything and everyone Realms of Ruin
will take you into the wild swamps of
Gir it's their sort of wild untamed land
where plenty of dangers are waiting not
just the cruel boys Relentless oric
attacks led by the psychopathic killer
boss dank fear threatened to overrun and
overwhelm an isolated dawnbringer
settlement sigrant commander of a
Detachment of stormcast eternals left
defending the settlement embark on a
perilous mission to obtain a great
magical power that will Aid them in
defeating the oryx and this sets in
motion a Savage battle for survival
which explores the inherent nature of
heroes and villains that draws them
inexorably towards their Fates
progress and succeed in combat you'll
unlock bigger and better units from the
Warhammer age of Sigma Universe what's
really excited me about Realms of Ruin
is that we're dealing with a tactical
strategic combat game but you can view
it how you want to you can pull the
camera all the way out get a really
really good overview of the battlefield
but equally push it all the way in it's
a really visually stunning game I love
looking at all the attention to detail
on the maps on the units on the
animations and the way that even they
idle to how they fight each other it's
just a real pleasure to watch I don't
think anyone's seen anything like this
in a real-time strategy game before
it's been excellent working with Games
Workshop and it's been great for all of
us to actually get time to spend with
the creative people from Games Workshop
and really collaborate to make Realms
have ruin the game that it's become
Frontiers Dev team brings a wealth of
artistic and Technical talent but also a
real love for the source material and a
strong desire to do it justice it's
really really exciting for us to finally
announce the game finally be able to
talk about it we've been working on it
for quite some time now and we're really
really glad we can start sharing it with
everyone there's a lot of love for the
universe and there's so much joy that
goes into the development process for
rounds of Ruin it's just really exciting
to finally be able to share that with
everyone you can't not be excited about
bringing these iconic managers to life
there's lots more to be revealed but if
I showed you now I'd be killed I'm not
sure I'll survive the reforging so make
sure you keep an eye on our social
channels for any upcoming announcements